aunque la reunión de putin y macro nayer
no se había traducido en principio en
acuerdos concretos esta mañana aquí en
que nos habíamos despertado con buenas
noticias porque desde el eligió se
informaba de que el presidente ruso le
había dicho a su colega francés que
estaba dispuesto a garantizar que no iba
a haber nuevas maniobras militares rusas
al otro lado de la frontera ucraniana al
menos de momento pero poco después el
kremlin ha echado agua fría sobre esas
declaraciones y ha dicho que ellos no
llegaron a ningún tipo de acuerdo en ese
sentido con los franceses hoy aquí en la
capital ucraniana el presidente francés
le ha trasladado a su colega ucraniano
las garantías de putin de que por parte
de rusia no haber una escalada
unilateral bélica el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski ha dicho
que se fía más de los hechos que de las
palabras del presidente ruso pero ha
apostado por seguir negociando dentro
del marco del formato de normandía